this photograph here you're probably
thinking why have I shown you a picture
of a suburban street it happens to be in
Blackpool which is quite interesting for
this discussion because what it shows is
a big crack and that crack was very
famous in Blackpool for a short time
because it purportedly appeared after an
earthquake which was related to fracking
rather nearby and people said that the
frack had appeared the crack it appeared
in the bridge and people also said that
motorbikes had fallen over than that and
the traffic lights stopped working and
things like that
now the bgs detected this earthquake and
our view was there's no way that the
energy of the earthquake could have
caused that crack and in fact if you
read the article which was attached to
this photograph if you got knocked down
to the bottom it said an old black poor
man said in fact that crack has been
there since 1972 so and but this this
characterizes the argument of shale gas
that there's an awful lot of stuff going
on which you can't tell is true or false
this is a game black ball and black pool
and net there are people saying on
websites that black pool at the coast
black book is at risk of sinking below
sea level and our sea sea defences will
have to be rebuilt essentially there is
no foundation whatsoever to this it
simply won't happen it's ridiculous so
this is going to be a little bit of the
spirit of my talk so - a bit of science
I'm sorry to show you a graph so early
but this is a famous graph from Pacolet
and sakulos science papers in 2004 and
these wedges are a bit like a scientific
unit of climate abatement if you like so
what is their way well a wedge would be
doubling global nuclear power a wedge
would be converting 2 billion cars from
30 miles per gallon to 60 miles began
another one is CCS on 800 power stations
and another one is gas now lamentably
there are very few figures about whether
shale gas or natural gas is truly more
green than other kinds of gas or other
kinds of energy the modelling and the
work studies haven't been done in
sufficient detail there is something
that was published by the
the European Commission about a month
ago which was about shale gas in
relation to other energy types and what
they said was in Poland it's extremely
dependent for its electricity on coal
something like 90 percent of this
electricity is generated from coal
if Poland converted overnight the shale
gas power stations which you probably
would like to do it would cut its
emissions by 41 to 49 percent which is a
very large cut so Poland would
immediately become a lot greener but
what about the world well essentially if
we take the high gas scenario of the IEA
from the comers for a golden age of gas
and it doesn't add up because they say
that you did the high gas use scenario
you get three point five degrees 2%
warming it is behind but of course gas
could be part of a wage it doesn't have
to be a series of wedges it could be one
wedge but there is a problem this is
where I'm gonna make my pitch to you
there's a real problem with these wedges
I said that there are several wedges
that have been described one shale gas
to nuclear
double global nuclear power three 800
CCS operations on 800 power stations
unfortunately the public won't have it
because all of them have the same
problem the same lack of belief amongst
the public and that might feed through
to policymakers and investors as well
they worry about it
the earth is scary people are frightened
of earthquakes look at this Somerset
expert reckons that if you do shale gas
than the men dips that will turn into a
volcano and people believe it you know
they people believe it and and this is
the quality of the debate that's out
there you know I'm not saying that shale
gas is the answer I'm not saying that
CCS is I'm not saying that double global
nuclear power either is but it's it's a
problem because if you if you want to do
these things they're all geological and
the public you know have many many
questions about the feasibility and the
safety of it I am arguing that science
needs to take a stronger role in this
particularly independence of science to
assess the risk and to do it publicly
and transparently and openly
and to talk about what snow race things
we don't have to worry about like
volcanoes and Blackpool disappearing
under the the Irish Sea high-risk things
and there are high-risk things there are
things that we should worry about like
methane getting into water supplies for
example these are things we should think
about if we did that we might get a
better quality debate we might have to
get better policy as well Thanks
you